do you normally drink quite a bit
after that last fight i went i think in
out of the eight weeks i drank like six
weekends in a row which was a lot for me
and i'm like there was like when i went
to miami with steven six like thursday
friday saturday we went hard three
nights in a row and that was [ __ ]
crazy but
i don't even want to go i don't even
after my fight i'm sure we'll drink go
like have the after party i'm like i
don't i i think back like even last
night i was thinking of some of the [ __ ]
i was doing when i was drunk and i'm
like that's embarrassing like what the
[ __ ] i was like acting like that but in
the moment it's like you're drunk
everyone's drunk everyone's acting a
fool but i'm like i don't even know if i
like that about me like
but then again it's just like i was i
was celebrating having fun whatever
wherever we're at doing whatever but
yeah alcohol's a weird thing
after you win and like you're walking
back are you like all right i'm about to
blaze it like what do you like
usually like can't wait for that first
load i don't like smoking and drinking
like mixing i don't like mixing those
two um because if i smoke i'm wanting to
chill the [ __ ] out yeah and like usually
after the fight it's like okay now it's
like we got to go out to the club we i
have an after party gotta go see the
boys gotta go you know we gotta
celebrate um
if i if right after the fight if i
smoked i would literally be in the hotel
room [ __ ] eating not giving a [ __ ]
about anything like just chilling yeah
so usually after the fight it's like
it depends this one might be different i
know i have an after party that's gonna
be you know at a club so i'm sure i'm
gonna have to you know take some shots
but i'm gonna try last time after that
last fight was the first time i blacked
out oh wow i feel like that was
terrifying like i'm like [ __ ] dude i
don't that was dangerous i feel like we
were texting after your last fight and
there's dude probably yeah
everybody he sent you dick pics dude
what do you think
that's so funny man yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]